What if you do not sleep at all?
Ah! Sleep. There can never be enough satisfaction
Actually. it often seems like we do not sleep enough
But what if we stopped sleeping?
Strangely, science understands little about sleep or how it has evolved since its inception.
First of all, stretching without feeling sleeping for hours,
at a time when someone looks at you, it seems difficult to look good or smart.
But we have discovered some correlations, for example:
Adults sleeping between 6-8 hours have the premise to live longer
Overuse can result in health problems such as: Cardiovascular Diseases and Diabetes.
Similarly, sleep deprivation is associated with cardiovascular disease, obesity, depression, and even brain damage.
But what if you stop sleeping at this moment?
After the first sleepless night, the metabolic system is stimulated and dopamine is rampant.
And this actually brings a lot of energy, positivity and sex.
Sounds delightful, but it's like a falling slope.
Your brain slowly begins to "exclude" the areas responsible for planning and evaluating decisions,
which implied impulsive behavior.
As soon as the waste begins, your reaction time begins to decrease
and perceptive and cognitive functions are reduced.
After one day or two without sleep the body loses its ability to
switched glucose and the immune system stops working properly
In some cases, 3 sleepless days lead to hallucinations.
You care how you look?
Studies have shown a fair correlation between deprivation of sleep and beauty of the person.
Let's say, deprived sleepers look less healthier
and less attractive than when they have been as quiet as they should.
The most long-lasting case of scientifically documented sleep is 246 hours or 11 days
And they show problems with concentration, perception, and readability.
The surprising truth is that they are not suffering from serious and long-term health effects.
In fact, none of the persons in these documented conditions did not
health, psychological, neurological or psychiatric problems.
But there are limited studies and this does not mean that permanent injuries can not be caused in more time.
Experiments with sleep deprivation in mice, for example, have led to their death after 2 weeks of no sleep
But scientists are not very sure if they have died of lack of sleep.
or by the stress caused by persistent awakening.
Maybe we should see FFI, a genetic brain disease
which causes progressively insomnia or insomnia
which leads to hallucinations, dementia and death.
This illness has affected only 100 people all over the world.
but the average life span was 18 months.
Over time, lack of sleep becomes worse and body organs begin to quench.
But lack of sleep does not kill fast,
persistent deprivation has nevimative effects on your body.
Sweet Dreams!
But not too much!